What's it take to put the past behind us? What's it take for a whole country to do it? Consider this story. After World War II, the Nuremberg trials documented German war crime atrocities and the Holocaust. But Germans didn't accept it. Historians have noted that, as far as the Germans were concerned, Nuremberg wasn't real justice. It was just a bunch of outsiders coming in after the war, imposing victor's justice.
我们该如何放下过去？一个国家要放下过去又需要什么？请看这个故事。二战结束后，纽伦堡审判记录了德国战争罪行的暴行和大屠杀。但德国人并不接受这一点。历史学家指出，在德国人看来，纽伦堡审判并不是真正的正义，只不过是一群外来者在战后闯入，强加了胜者的正义。
It wasn't until the 1960s, when the Germans held their own homegrown war crimes trials, that the Germans were forced to face what they'd done as a nation during the war. And even that wasn't enough. As one writer put it, it took an accumulation of a million school visits to concentration camps, 1,000 books, the Hollywood television series, Holocaust, a vast molecular reckoning between generations that's still going on.
直到20世纪60年代，德国举行了本土的战争罪行审判，德国人才被迫面对他们在战争期间作为一个国家所犯下的罪行。即便如此还不够。正如一位作家所言，这需要数以百万计的学校参观集中营活动、一千本书籍、好莱坞电视剧《大屠杀》，以及几代人之间至今仍在持续的巨大心理清算。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, how to come to peace with the past, stories of people running toward and running from the truth and shame. Act One, International Justice, an entire nation coming to grips with the past--or actually, not coming to grips with the past. Act Two, Juvenile Justice, criminals face their past-- juvenile criminals. We have a report from Scott Carrier. Act Three, Everyday Justice, ordinary New Yorkers confessing their sins, quietly, in public. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目将探讨如何与过去和解，讲述人们奔向真相与羞耻，或是逃避真相与羞耻的故事。第一幕，国际正义，整个国家正在努力面对过去——或者说，其实并没有面对过去。第二幕，少年司法，罪犯面对他们的过去——少年罪犯。我们有来自斯科特·卡里尔的报道。第三幕，日常正义，普通纽约人在公共场合悄悄承认自己的罪过。请继续收听。
Act One. Well, ever since the end of World War II, there's been this idealistic notion kicking around that when nations do horrible things, the best way to deal with it, to put those things to rest, would be to have a court somewhere, a court for war crimes, for crimes against humanity. And now, for the first time since the Nuremberg and Tokyo trials at the end of World War II, a court like this is actually in session. This is the war crimes tribunal for the former Yugoslavia.
第一幕。好吧，自从二战结束以来，一直存在一种理想主义的观念，认为当国家犯下滔天大罪时，处理它、平息它的最好方法就是在某处设立一个法庭，一个审判战争罪和反人类罪的法庭。现在，这是自二战结束时纽伦堡和东京审判以来的第一次，这样的法庭实际上正在开庭。这就是前南斯拉夫战争罪行法庭。
Just like the Nuremberg trials, this is justice administered by outsiders. These trials are happening far from the Balkans. They're in the Hague, in the Netherlands. There are lawyers and judges from Egypt, and France, and Sri Lanka, and Canada, and lots of Americans there. Kitty Felde is a familiar voice to public radio listeners for her coverage of the O. J. Simpson trial and the Rodney King beating trial, but over the course of the last year, she spent several weeks in the Hague, watching this new form of justice take place.
就像纽伦堡审判一样，这是由外来者实施的正义。这些审判发生在远离巴尔干半岛的地方。它们在荷兰的海牙进行。那里有来自埃及、法国、斯里兰卡、加拿大和许多美国的律师和法官。基蒂·费尔德是公共广播听众非常熟悉的声音，她曾报道过辛普森杀妻案和罗德尼·金殴打案，但在过去的一年里，她花了几个星期在海牙，观察这种新的司法形式。
Gabrielle Kirk McDonald is arguably the most powerful African-American woman in the world, but you've probably never heard of her. McDonald is the presiding judge for the first international war crimes trial in half a century. As she sits in her judicial robes week after week inside the courtroom, it becomes clear that Judge McDonald is like most Americans when it comes to things foreign. We can't read the maps.
加布里埃尔·柯克·麦克唐纳可以说是世界上最有权势的非裔美国女性，但你可能从未听说过她。麦克唐纳是半个世纪以来第一次国际战争罪审判的首席法官。当她周复一周地坐在法庭上的法官席上时，很明显，对于外国事务，麦克唐纳法官就像大多数美国人一样。我们读不懂地图。
Mr. [? Doko ?] was from [? Boski-- ?] [? Boskisamic, ?] maybe, was he? Somewhere up there, as I recall.
多科先生来自……也许是波斯基萨米克，他是吗？我记得大概在那个方向。
We don't know the history, and we have the devil of a time pronouncing the names.
我们不懂这段历史，而且我们读这些名字简直是受罪。
The witness, Mr. Gros-- Grovs-- Grovesdenat--
证人，格罗斯……格罗夫斯……格罗夫斯德纳特……
[? Grozenich ?], yes, your Honor.
格罗泽尼奇，是的，法官大人。
Anyway, he testified.
不管怎样，他作证了。
But Judge McDonald also brings to the tribunal another American attribute-- her idealism.
但麦克唐纳法官也为法庭带来了另一种美国特质——她的理想主义。
I love the law. I like solving problems, and I think, for, certainly, a racial minority, I think that the use of our laws in the United States is the way that we bring about equality and inclusion.
我热爱法律。我喜欢解决问题，而且我认为，对于少数族裔来说，我认为在美国运用我们的法律是实现平等和包容的途径。
And McDonald isn't the only American working at the tribunal.
麦克唐纳并不是唯一在法庭工作的美国人。
By the time you left [UNINTELLIGIBLE], about 90% of the Muslim community had been killed, forced out.
当你离开[听不清]时，大约90%的穆斯林社区成员已经被杀害或被迫离开。
Prosecutor Alan Tieger is on loan to the tribunal from the Department of Justice. About two dozen American lawyers, investigators, and other experts have been seconded-- or loaned out-- to the tribunal, their salaries paid by the US government. Americans make up the largest legal community at the tribunal. The contingent is so large, some complain that through sheer numbers, they're turning what's supposed to be a brand-new legal system into something that looks a lot like US Constitutional law.
检察官艾伦·蒂格是司法部借调给法庭的。大约有二十多名美国律师、调查员和其他专家被借调到法庭，他们的工资由美国政府支付。美国人是法庭上最大的法律群体。这一队伍如此庞大，以至于有人抱怨说，他们纯粹靠人数，正在把一个本应是全新的法律体系，变得看起来非常像美国的宪法法律。
Most of the Americans are here out of a sense of moral conviction. Alan Tieger, like Judge McDonald, was a civil rights lawyer. He was one of the prosecutors at the federal Rodney King beating trial. His parents were Holocaust survivors. The prosecution's chief investigator, Terree Bowers, says he came to the Hague to do work of significance to humankind. But from the start, his new job presented challenges he never faced in his old position as head of the US Attorney's Office in Los Angeles.
大多数美国人来到这里是出于一种道德信念。艾伦·蒂格和麦克唐纳法官一样，曾是一名民权律师。他是联邦罗德尼·金殴打案的检察官之一。他的父母是大屠杀幸存者。检方首席调查员特里·鲍尔斯说，他来到海牙是为了做对人类有意义的工作。但从一开始，这份新工作就带来了他以前在洛杉矶担任美国联邦检察官办公室负责人时从未面临过的挑战。
I mean, when we went into Tuzla, we flew into the airport, and the next morning, the Serbs started shelling the airport. So we weren't even able to get out. Where you have to dodge artillery, and some areas you just can't get into, immediately, we knew that we were up against an enormous challenge to put these cases together.
我是说，当我们进入图兹拉时，我们飞抵机场，第二天早上，塞尔维亚人就开始炮击机场。所以我们甚至无法离开。在必须躲避炮火的地方，在一些你根本无法立即进入的地区，我们知道，要整理这些案件，我们面临着巨大的挑战。
There were all sorts of challenges. And one thing in particular that Americans, and other non-Yugoslavs at the tribunal found so very difficult to understand-- the now familiar stories of neighbor turning against neighbor, almost overnight. Judge McDonald asked witness after witness about this, over and over again.
挑战随处可见。特别有一件事让美国人和其他非南斯拉夫籍的法庭人员感到难以理解——那就是现在已经司空见惯的邻居反目成仇的故事，几乎在一夜之间就发生了。麦克唐纳法官一次又一次地问证人这个问题。
I guess my question, and perhaps it's not a fair question, I don't know that you could give a complete answer, but perhaps you can help me to understand since I am not from that area, how could you explain that some of the atrocities that we've heard have been committed? How can you explain that something like that would happen, given your background, given your experience, knowing that Serbs and Muslims lived together, went to school together, intermarried? How did it happen?
我想我的问题，也许不是一个公平的问题，我不知道你能不能给出一个完整的回答，但也许你能帮助我理解，因为我不是那个地区的人，你能解释一下我们所听说的一些暴行是如何犯下的吗？考虑到你的背景，考虑到你的经历，知道塞尔维亚人和穆斯林曾经住在一起、一起上学、通婚，你能解释这种事怎么会发生吗？这到底是怎么发生的？
She never found an answer that satisfied her. And as the trial wore on, she and other judges found themselves searching for something in their own experiences to explain it. And that raises this question, what does it mean when people with one sort of history are trying and judging people with a very different sort?
她从来没有找到一个让她满意的答案。随着审判的进行，她和其他法官发现自己正在从各自的经历中寻找解释。这就引出了一个问题：当有着一种历史的人试图审判有着完全不同历史的人时，这意味着什么？
The International Criminal Tribunal for the former Yugoslavia is now in session. [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Please be seated.
前南斯拉夫国际刑事法庭现在开庭。[讲外语] 请就座。
It was back in May of 1993 that the United Nations Security Council set up the tribunal at the urging of the US and Western Europe. At the time, NATO was resisting pleas from the Bosnians to come to their aid in the war, and cynics suggested that the West set up the tribunal simply because it was easier to commit lawyers than troops.
那是1993年5月，联合国安理会在美国和西欧的敦促下成立了该法庭。当时，北约正在抗拒波斯尼亚人要求在战争中援助他们的请求，愤世嫉俗者认为，西方成立该法庭只是因为派律师比派军队更容易。
Some people feel that the tribunal was created as kind of an apology because the world community wasn't doing anything.
有些人觉得成立该法庭是一种道歉，因为国际社会什么也没做。
Again, Judge McDonald.
再次引用麦克唐纳法官的话。
I don't care. I don't care what their reason was. The point is that we have been established. And I think that we're making a contribution.
我不在乎。我不在乎他们的理由是什么。关键是我们已经成立了。而且我认为我们正在做出贡献。
But to see just how difficult it is to make a contribution, consider the case of Witness L. The tribunal allows witnesses who fear for their lives to testify behind closed doors, their identities secret. Witness L explained to the tribunal that he was a guard at one of the Serb-run prison camps, where he witnessed the tribunal's first defendant, a Bosnian Serb karate teacher named Dusan Tadic, commit more crimes.
但要看看做出贡献有多难，考虑一下L证人的案例。法庭允许担心生命安全的证人闭门作证，身份保密。L证人向法庭解释说，他是塞尔维亚人经营的集中营的一名看守，在那里他亲眼目睹了法庭的首位被告，一名叫杜尚·塔迪奇的波斯尼亚塞族空手道教练犯下了更多的罪行。
The prosecution had other witnesses who told of Tadic delivering brutal beatings, but L was the only credible witness who saw Tadic rape and kill people. L testified about one incident where 10 elderly men were taken into the infamous white house, the scene of most tortures at the Omarska prison camp.
检方有其他证人讲述了塔迪奇施加残暴殴打的经历，但L是唯一可信的目击者，他看到塔迪奇强奸和杀害他人。L作证称，有一次，10名老人在奥马尔斯卡集中营的大多数酷刑发生地——那座臭名昭著的白房子里被带走。
According to L, Tadic pointed to him and said, "Come here and perform the killing of these 10 prisoners." L answered, "Why me? Why do I have to do it?" Tadic apparently grew impatient. L said Tadic approached the prisoners and shot two of them in the head, point blank. It was dramatic, damning testimony, the strongest brought forward by the prosecution.
据L说，塔迪奇指着他，说：“过来，把这10名囚犯杀了。”L回答说：“为什么是我？为什么非要我杀？”塔迪奇显然不耐烦了。L说，塔迪奇走向囚犯，对着其中两人的头部近距离开枪。这是戏剧性且定罪力极强的证词，是检方提出的最有力的证据。
Unfortunately, it wasn't true. Two months after L's initial court appearance, prosecutors had to stand before the court and admit that L had lied on the stand. He had never been a camp guard. He'd never witnessed the alleged atrocities. He'd never even seen Dusan Tadic in person until he walked into the courtroom. Prosecution investigator Robert Reid told the court L was a Bosnian Serb soldier. He said he'd been caught by the Bosnian Muslim army, and then was coerced into testifying.
不幸的是，这不是真的。在L首次出庭两个月后，检察官不得不站在法庭前承认L在证人席上撒了谎。他从来不是集中营看守。他从未目睹过所谓的暴行。他甚至在走进法庭之前，从未亲眼见过杜尚·塔迪奇。检方调查员罗伯特·里德告诉法庭，L是一名波斯尼亚塞族士兵。他说他被波斯尼亚穆斯林军队抓获，然后被迫作证。
He said that after his initial interview by the military, he was transferred to Sarajevo, where he spoke with police interrogators for seven hours a day, for about one month. The purpose of these conversations was to train Witness L to give evidence against [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Tadic. I then asked him why he'd pleaded guilty to something that he had never done, and he stated that he'd been threatened that if he did not cooperate with the Bosnian authorities, that he'd be executed.
他说，在军方对他进行初步审讯后，他被转移到萨拉热窝，在那里他每天与警察审讯员交谈七小时，持续了大约一个月。这些谈话的目的是训练L证人提供针对塔迪奇的证据。我随后问他为什么承认自己从未做过的事情，他表示自己受到了威胁，如果他不与波斯尼亚当局合作，他就会被处决。
In the weeks since then, the prosecution says it's uncovered new evidence that shows the Bosnian Serb government didn't coach Witness L. At this point, it's unclear what to believe of his testimony, and the whole episode raises disturbing questions for the Americans and Western Europeans who first pushed for the establishment of the international criminal tribunal.
在随后的几周里，检方表示已发现新证据，显示波斯尼亚塞族政府并没有教唆L证人。目前，他的证词有多少可信尚不清楚，整个事件为最初推动建立国际刑事法庭的美国人和西欧人提出了令人不安的问题。
If these trials were designed to get at the truth, they were being tainted by a witness who lied. If they were trying to bring justice to the victims, it was those victims-- the Muslims, in this case-- who were fabricating evidence, trying to swing the verdict their way.
如果这些审判旨在查明真相，那么它们被一名撒谎的证人玷污了。如果他们试图为受害者伸张正义，那么正是那些受害者——在这个案例中是穆斯林——在编造证据，试图改变判决结果以利于自己。
The accused, would you rise, please, and state your identity, Mr. Erdemovic.
被告，请站起来，说明你的身份，埃尔德莫维奇先生。
Drazen Erdemovic. I was born in Tuzla in 1971. I'm a Croat by nationality.
德拉岑·埃尔德莫维奇。我于1971年出生在图兹拉。我是克罗地亚族人。
Thus far, the tribunal has only handed down one sentence. It's a case where no one disputes the basic facts of the crime. This was the case of Drazen Erdemovic. It's a story of a man who risked his life and his freedom to tell the world the truth about what he'd done.
迄今为止，法庭只做出了一个判决。这是一个没有人对犯罪的基本事实提出异议的案件。这就是德拉岑·埃尔德莫维奇案。这是一个为了向世界说出他所作所为的真相，而冒着生命和自由危险的男人的故事。
Erdemovic is 25, a baby-faced kid with acne scars. He's Croatian. His wife is a Serb. They have a young son. Erdemovic was trained as a tool and dye maker. But by the time he had learned his trade, the war had broken out, so he became a career soldier, and served with all three armies during the war. But he says he chose combat units that conducted reconnaissance missions and manned border checkpoints, jobs where he didn't have to kill anyone.
埃尔德莫维奇25岁，长着一张满是痤疮疤痕的娃娃脸。他是克罗地亚人。他的妻子是塞尔维亚人。他们有一个年幼的儿子。埃尔德莫维奇受过模具制造师的训练。但在他学会手艺时，战争爆发了，所以他成了职业军人，在战争期间为所有三支军队服役。但他表示，他选择了执行侦察任务和在边境检查站值守的作战部队，这些工作不需要他杀死任何人。
Until July of 1995, that's when his special battalion of the Bosnian Serb army, the 10th sabotage unit, was ordered to a farm field near Pilica. It was shortly after the fall of Srebrenica. The UN had set up a safe area there, where 25,000 Bosnian Muslims had fled for protection. But when the Bosnian Serb army attacked, the tiny UN force didn't offer much resistance. In fact, UN peacekeepers helped load Muslim men onto buses that took them away, never to be seen again.
直到1995年7月，当时他的波斯尼亚塞族军队特种营——第10破坏部队，接到命令前往皮利察附近的一块农田。那是在斯雷布雷尼察陷落后不久。联合国在那里设立了一个安全区，25,000名波斯尼亚穆斯林逃到那里寻求保护。但当波斯尼亚塞族军队进攻时，小规模的联合国部队没有进行多少抵抗。事实上，联合国维和人员帮助将穆斯林男性装上巴士，把他们带走，从此再也没人见过他们。
Erdemovic and his unit had been given instructions on how to kill large numbers of people in a short period of time. And then the buses started arriving. The first group of 10 wore blindfolds, their hands tied behind their backs. Erdemovic and his comrades were then ordered to shoot the prisoners in the back.
埃尔德莫维奇和他的部队接到了如何在短时间内杀死大量人员的指示。然后巴士开始抵达。第一组10人戴着眼罩，双手被绑在背后。埃尔德莫维奇和他的战友随后接到命令，向囚犯背后开枪。
I was sorry for those people, simply. I had no reason to shoot at those people. They had done nothing to me.
我只是为那些人感到难过。我没有理由向那些人开枪。他们对我什么也没做。
But Erdemovic emptied his rifle again and again, killing as many as 100 of the 1,200 killed that day.
但埃尔德莫维奇一次又一次地清空了他的步枪，在当天被杀的1,200人中，他杀死了多达100人。
Your honor, I had to do this. If I had refused, I would've been killed together with the victims. When I refused, they told me, if you're sorry for them, stand up, line up with them, and we will kill you, too.
法官大人，我不得不这样做。如果我拒绝，我就会和受害者一起被杀。当我拒绝时，他们告诉我，如果你为他们感到难过，就站过去，和他们站在一起，我们也会杀了你。
Erdemovic's unit was then ordered to a nearby town where, perhaps, 500 other Bosnian Muslims were being held inside a meeting hall. He and his unit were ordered to kill them as well. Erdemovic says, this time, he did refuse, saying, wasn't there enough blood? Weren't there enough dead people? Erdemovic says he didn't care what happened to himself anymore. He told American prosecutor Mark Harmon, "I didn't want to become a robot for extermination."
埃尔德莫维奇的部队随后接到命令前往附近的一个城镇，那里可能有500名其他波斯尼亚穆斯林被关在一个会议厅里。他和他的部队也接到命令要杀死他们。埃尔德莫维奇说，这次他拒绝了，问难道血流得还不够多吗？难道死的人还不够多吗？埃尔德莫维奇说他不再在乎自己的命运了。他告诉美国检察官马克·哈蒙：“我不想成为一台灭绝机器。”
Are you able to estimate how many people you killed?
你能估计一下你杀死了多少人吗？
I don't know exactly. I can't estimate. But to be quite frank, I'd rather not know how many people I killed.
我不确切知道。我没法估计。但说实话，我宁愿不知道我杀死了多少人。
Erdemovic's refusal to kill again did not go unnoticed by his comrades. A few days later, in a bar fight, one of them shot him four times. Erdemovic says it was because they knew he couldn't keep his mouth shut. And he couldn't. Erdemovic says after the massacre, he couldn't sleep. He stayed away from home and drank. After he had partially recovered from the gunshot wounds, he says he finally decided to tell his story to the war crimes tribunal. But there was no tribunal representative anywhere nearby.
埃尔德莫维奇拒绝再次杀人，这引起了战友的注意。几天后，在一场酒吧斗殴中，其中一个人朝他开了四枪。埃尔德莫维奇说这是因为他们知道他无法保守秘密。他也确实无法保守。埃尔德莫维奇说，大屠杀过后，他无法入睡。他远离家乡，酗酒。在部分从枪伤中康复后，他说他最终决定把他的故事告诉战争罪行法庭。但附近根本没有任何法庭代表。
So he went to the American embassy in Belgrade. They gave him a list of news agencies. He called the first one on the list and told his story to a stringer for ABC News. Unfortunately, the phones were tapped, and the reporter's tapes were confiscated at the airport. Erdemovic was quickly arrested, but not before he had talked to another reporter with the Paris daily paper, Le Figaro. His story of the Pilica massacre was translated and retold all over the world. Erdemovic eventually made his way to the tribunal, where he told his story again.
于是他去了贝尔格莱德的美国大使馆。他们给了他一份新闻机构名单。他打了名单上的第一个电话，向ABC新闻的一名特约记者讲述了他的故事。不幸的是，电话被窃听了，记者的磁带在机场被没收。埃尔德莫维奇很快被捕，但在那之前，他曾与巴黎日报《费加罗报》的另一名记者谈过。关于皮利察大屠杀的故事被翻译出来，并在世界各地流传。埃尔德莫维奇最终设法找到了法庭，在那里他再次讲述了自己的故事。
I just wanted the truth to be known, and for someone to understand that this actually happened, and how these people had lost their lives. Because as we heard today, nobody knew about the place of Pilica, that a crime had happened there, and what kind of crime. Perhaps that's where most people were killed. And to have someone believe me, that I really had to do it, that I didn't want to do it, that's why.
我只是想让真相大白，让有人明白这确实发生了，这些人是如何失去生命的。因为正如我们今天所听到的，没有人知道皮利察这个地方，那里发生过罪行，以及是什么样的罪行。也许那是大多数人被杀的地方。而要让有人相信我，我确实不得不这样做，我不愿意这样做，这就是原因。
Judges deciding his case had a difficult time understanding how Erdemovic got himself into such a no-win situation. Why didn't he just flee the country? Erdemovic explained, you couldn't get a passport until you'd completed your military service. And by then, the war had broken out. Egyptian judge Fouad Riad questioned why he kept enlisting in the army.
负责审理他案件的法官们很难理解埃尔德莫维奇是如何让自己陷入这种无路可走的境地的。为什么他不逃离这个国家？埃尔德莫维奇解释说，在你服完兵役之前，你拿不到护照。而到那时，战争已经爆发了。埃及法官福阿德·里亚德质问他为什么要继续参军。
You pleaded very much the cause of peace. At the same time, you happened to join all the fighting groups during this war. Wasn't there any other way to express your belief in coexistence?
你极力为和平辩护。与此同时，你却恰好在战争期间加入了所有的战斗组织。难道没有其他方式来表达你对共存的信念了吗？
How shall I put it? We were forced to join the army. I had received those call-up papers. I had no one to turn to. Who was I? I was just a simple Drazen Erdemovic with nobody who would listen to me.
我该怎么说呢？我们是被迫参军的。我收到了那些征兵令。我无人可求。我是谁？我只是一个普通的德拉岑·埃尔德莫维奇，没有人会听我说。
Erdemovic grew increasingly frustrated at the judges' questioning. He cried several times on the stand. At one point, he and the French judge Claude Jorda began shouting at each other in their native languages, neither one waiting for translation.
埃尔德莫维奇对法官的质问越来越感到沮丧。他在证人席上哭了好几次。有一次，他和法国法官克劳德·乔达开始用各自的母语大声争吵，两人都没有等翻译。
[SPEAKING FRENCH].
[法语讲话]。
I was against the war. I didn't want the war. I had no motives. I had no motivation to go to war. Is there anyone here who can understand me? My wife is a Serb. Was I supposed to hate her because she is a Serbian? I apologize, but let me explain this to you. I do understand this, but this is the 12th time that I'm repeating my story, the story of how my life has been destroyed. Please try to understand me. This is the 12th time I'm doing this.
我反对战争。我不想要这场战争。我没有动机。我没有动力去参战。这里有人能理解我吗？我的妻子是塞尔维亚人。我应该因为她是塞尔维亚人而恨她吗？我很抱歉，但让我向你们解释一下。我确实理解这一点，但这已经是我第12次重复我的故事了，关于我的生活是如何被摧毁的故事。请试着理解我。这是我第12次这样做。
Erdemovic even pulled up his shirt to show the two-foot scar on his belly, the result of several operations to repair damage done by his comrade's bullets. Judge Jorda was unmoved.
埃尔德莫维奇甚至撩起衬衫，展示了他腹部两英尺长的伤疤，那是为了修复战友子弹造成的伤害而进行多次手术的结果。乔达法官不为所动。
I understand that it is painful for you. We understand that you were caught in a storm, but that is not a reason for us, just like that, to say that these many, many people who were killed simply will be written off.
我理解这对你来说很痛苦。我们理解你被困在风暴中，但这并不是我们仅仅因为这样，就说这么多被杀的人会被一笔勾销的理由。
Prosecutors say they never would have known what had happened to those 1,200 victims if Erdemovic had not come forward. Yet the tribunal judges sentenced him to 10 years behind bars for his role in the killings, dismissing his claims that he had no choice but to shoot. The judges said they only had his word on it.
检方表示，如果埃尔德莫维奇没有挺身而出，他们永远不会知道那1,200名受害者发生了什么。然而，法庭法官判处他10年监禁，因为他在杀人事件中的角色，驳回了他声称他别无选择只能开枪的说法。法官们表示，他们只有他的一面之词。
So here, the tribunal has sentenced its first war criminal, a kid they have in custody only because he chose to come forward and tell his story. And yet, the colonel who gave the orders to shoot hasn't even been charged with a crime. And while General Ratko Mladic, the military men at the top, has been indicted, he, like dozens of other indicted war criminals, remains a free man.
所以，法庭判处了它的第一个战争罪犯，一个他们之所以能拘留他，只是因为他选择挺身而出讲述自己的故事。然而，下令开枪的上校甚至没有被指控犯罪。虽然最高层的军事人物拉特科·姆拉迪奇将军已经被起诉，但他和其他几十名被起诉的战争罪犯一样，仍然是一个自由人。
Is this justice, punishing only the small fish? Louise Arbour, the Canadian chief prosecutor at the tribunal, gets angry when Erdemovic is described as a little fish.
这就是正义吗，只惩罚小鱼小虾？法庭的加拿大首席检察官路易丝·阿尔布尔听到埃尔德莫维奇被描述为小鱼时非常生气。
How small a fish can you be when you're prepared to admit to the killing of 100 people? By any national standard, this would be the biggest crime in the history of that country. And so I find that level of cynicism a bit disconcerting, that people are saying, well, don't waste my time with mere killers of hundreds, I'd like to see killers of thousands.
当你准备承认杀害了100人时，你还能有多小？按照任何国家的标准，这都将是该国历史上最大的罪行。所以我发现那种愤世嫉俗的程度有点令人不安，人们说，好吧，别拿杀了几百人的小角色来浪费我的时间，我想看到杀了几千人的凶手。
Which brings us to the biggest problem facing the tribunal. Unlike most criminal justice systems, the tribunal has no police force of its own. And so it has no way of bringing fugitives to justice. The Yugoslav tribunal has indicted 75 people so far. One has died, seven are in custody, and the rest are working and living free in the former Yugoslavia.
这就引出了法庭面临的最大问题。与大多数刑事司法系统不同，法庭没有自己的警察部队。因此，它没有办法将逃犯绳之以法。南斯拉夫法庭到目前为止已经起诉了75人。一人死亡，七人在押，其余的人在前南斯拉夫自由地生活和工作。
Under the Dayton Accord, the Bosnian, Serbian, and Croatian governments are supposed to hand over indicted war criminals living in their territories. With rare exceptions, this hasn't happened. Under Dayton, NATO troops are also authorized to make arrests of any indicted war criminals they encounter. The joke at the tribunal is that NATO troops have to cross the street not to run into them.
根据《代顿协议》，波斯尼亚、塞尔维亚和克罗地亚政府应该交出居住在其境内的被起诉的战争罪犯。除了极少数例外，这种情况并没有发生。根据《代顿协议》，北约部队也获准逮捕他们遇到的任何被起诉的战争罪犯。法庭上的笑话是，北约部队必须穿过马路，以免撞上他们。
If the international community doesn't follow through with its commitment to the tribunal, if indicted war criminals are allowed to remain free, it sends exactly the opposite message from the one Americans at the tribunal were hoping to send. It says, essentially, that future Karadzics and Mladics can commit any atrocities they want, and the world won't bother to bring them to justice.
如果国际社会不履行其对法庭的承诺，如果被起诉的战争罪犯被允许逍遥法外，它传达的信息与法庭上的美国人希望传达的信息完全相反。这基本上是在说，未来的卡拉季奇们和姆拉迪奇们可以犯下他们想要的任何暴行，而世界根本不会费心把他们绳之以法。
The Dutch, like most Europeans, are not a particularly church-going people. Every small town boasts of a beautiful cathedral, but it's usually empty. When a holiday called [? Tweede ?] Pinksteren rolled around one Monday, none of the locals in the court knew it was, and we foreigners had to consultant a liturgical calendar to find out it was the second day of Pentecost.
荷兰人，像大多数欧洲人一样，并不是特别虔诚的宗教信徒。每个小镇都有美丽的大教堂，但通常是空的。当一个叫“Tweede Pinksteren”的节日在一个星期一到来时，法庭里的当地人没人知道它是什么，我们这些外国人不得不查阅礼仪日历才知道这是五旬节的第二天。
So here in the midst of this rather secular society is a trial about another society, where religious divisions became a matter of life and death. And in this setting, those who come to work every day at the tribunal are the truly faithful. The world community won't arrest the criminals they indict, those who fought the war don't seem particularly interested in the truth about it, the international media ignores what they're doing, but still, the lawyers and the judges come in and examine evidence, they work on their cases, true believers in the idea that the rule of law is the only way to create a lasting peace.
所以，在这个相当世俗的社会中，进行着一场关于另一个社会的审判，在那个社会，宗教分歧成了生与死的问题。在这种环境下，那些每天来法庭工作的人是真正的信徒。国际社会不会逮捕他们起诉的罪犯，那些打仗的人似乎对真相并不感兴趣，国际媒体忽视了他们的工作，但律师和法官们依然进来审查证据，他们处理案件，坚信法治是创造持久和平的唯一途径。
Sitting there day after day, I remembered an old Islamic proverb that says one hour of doing justice is worth 100 in prayer. They come to this brick temple of a courthouse every day to do their praying by working for justice, even if no one hears their prayer.
日复一日地坐在那里，我想起一句古老的伊斯兰谚语，说“一个小时的正义胜过一百小时的祈祷”。他们每天来到这座砖砌的法庭圣殿，通过为正义工作来祈祷，即使没有人听到他们的祈祷。
[PRAYING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[用外语祈祷]
That story by Kitty Felde. There's this remarkable essay about war crimes trials and national truth commissions by Michael Ignatieff, in the current issue of Index on Censorship. Ignatieff is writing a book on truth and national reconciliation, and he's examining the war crimes trial in the Hague, and the one in Rwanda, and the truth commissions in Argentina, and Chile, and South Africa, the situation in Ireland. And in this essay, he writes, "It's open to question whether justice or truth actually heals. For one thing," he says, "what you see as the truth depends on who you are."
那是基蒂·费尔德的报道。在目前的《审查索引》（Index on Censorship）杂志上，迈克尔·伊格纳蒂耶夫写了一篇关于战争罪审判和国家真相委员会的卓越文章。伊格纳蒂耶夫正在写一本关于真相与民族和解的书，他正在审视海牙的战争罪审判、卢旺达的审判，以及阿根廷、智利和南非的真相委员会，还有爱尔兰的局势。他在文中写道：“正义或真相是否真的能治愈，是有待商榷的。一方面，”他说，“你看到的真相取决于你是谁。”
He tells this story. In June of 1996, he was asked to chair a discussion of historians from Serbia, Croatia, and Bosnia. And all of these had been people who had opposed the war. Most of them, in fact, had been close friends before the war. And they hadn't given in to the national hatreds inflamed by the war. They'd remained friends. It was about 30 people.
他讲了这样一个故事。1996年6月，他被邀请主持一场由来自塞尔维亚、克罗地亚和波斯尼亚的历史学家参加的讨论。所有这些人都是反对战争的人。事实上，大多数人在战前是亲密朋友。他们没有屈服于战争激起的民族仇恨。他们仍然是朋友。大约有30人。
And I got them around a table, and I asked them, at one point, don't you think it would be possible for you all to get together and produce a history of the war that is a simple narrative of how this catastrophe happened to your three societies? There was a kind of deafening silence after I made this liberal, well-meaning proposal.
我让他们围坐在桌子旁，我问他们，你们不认为你们所有人聚在一起，写出一部关于这场战争的简单叙事史，说明这场灾难是如何降临到你们三个社会的是可能的吗？在我提出这个开明、善意的建议后，出现了一种令人窒息的沉默。
And people then just said, a common history is impossible. We couldn't do it. We couldn't even agree what events should be included. We couldn't even agree on when the war began. I mean, some people think the war began in June 1991 when the JNA tanks marched into Slovenia. Other people think the war began in '85 and '86 when Serbian nationalism began to take off.
然后人们只是说，共同的历史是不可能的。我们做不到。我们甚至无法就应该包含哪些事件达成一致。我们甚至无法就战争何时开始达成一致。我的意思是，有些人认为战争始于1991年6月南斯拉夫人民军坦克开进斯洛文尼亚时。另一些人认为战争始于85年和86年，当时塞尔维亚民族主义开始抬头。
Even simple factual questions become, in other words, questions of attribution of responsibility and questions of guilt. I mean, it'll take generations, and I'm not sure that outsiders can do it. It's like a family trauma. And as a family, they will have to talk it out. But it will take 30, 40, 50 years.
换句话说，即使是简单的事实问题，也变成了责任归属问题和罪责问题。我的意思是，这将需要几代人的时间，而且我不确定外来者能否做到。这就像家庭创伤。作为一个家庭，他们必须谈开。但这需要30、40、50年。
So what do you make of this notion of the Americans and the other foreigners who are holding the tribunal that, OK, we're going to get at the truth?
那么，你如何看待美国人和在法庭工作的其他外国人持有的这种观点，即好吧，我们要查明真相？
Well, I don't want to be cynical about that, because I think juridical truth is terribly important. And here, I think, outsiders can play a limited role, because an outsider can say, here are the forensic facts about certain war crimes, and we can establish them. An international tribunal can establish what war crimes happened, where, by whom, and to whom.
嗯，我不想对此持愤世嫉俗的态度，因为我认为司法真相非常重要。在这里，我认为外来者可以发挥有限的作用，因为外来者可以说，这是关于某些战争罪行的法医事实，我们可以确定它们。国际法庭可以确定发生了什么战争罪行、在哪里、由谁以及对谁犯下。
There's no guarantee that that truth will then reach out through the society at large, but at least it constitutes one kind of place, somewhere, where honest men can find what actually happened.
无法保证这种真相会随之传达到整个社会，但至少它构成了某个地方的一个场所，在那里诚实的人可以找到实际发生了什么。
Right, but it's just a first step.
没错，但这只是第一步。
Absolutely a first step. And it would be naive to think that when the tribunal winds up its work in so many years' time, and all the volumes of evidence are published, that this is of itself going to make much difference. I mean, the really scary thing is the sense in which in a lot of Serbian society and Croatian society, the conclusions and even the evidence of the Hague are discounted before it's even heard, as being, you know, this kind of alien enemy, nobody understands this but ourselves, that kind of line. You know, no one understands the Serbs but the Serbs, no one understands the Croats but the Croats, no one understands the Muslims but the Muslims, and therefore, anything that an international tribunal says to them has to be wrong.
绝对是第一步。如果认为当法庭在多年后结束工作，所有证据卷宗出版时，这本身就会产生多大影响，那就太天真了。我的意思是，真正可怕的是，在许多塞尔维亚社会和克罗地亚社会，海牙的结论甚至证据在被听到之前就被否定了，被认为，你知道，这是一种异己的敌人，除了我们自己，没人明白这一点，那种论调。你知道，没人理解塞尔维亚人，除了塞尔维亚人自己，没人理解克罗地亚人，除了克罗地亚人自己，没人理解穆斯林，除了穆斯林自己，因此，国际法庭对他们说的任何话都一定是错的。
It's such an interesting contrast to a place like South Africa where, as you point out in your essay, you have former adversaries actually sitting down trying to create a government, trying to create a nation where all sides are represented. And so when they sit down and hold a truth commission themselves, not outsiders but they, themselves, because they are ready to reconcile and have been part of a process of reconciliation, there's a place for that truth to go. It can actually have an effect. There's a readiness for it.
这与南非这样的地方形成了鲜明的对比，正如你在文章中指出的那样，你有前敌对双方实际上坐在一起试图建立一个政府，试图建立一个所有各方都有代表的民族。所以当他们坐下来并自己举行真相委员会时，不是外来者，而是他们自己，因为他们准备和解并参与了和解过程，真相就有了一个归宿。它实际上可以产生影响。人们做好了准备。
Yes. The tragedy in the Balkans is that, at the moment, there's no place for the truth to go, because the regimes that are in power, all of them-- and I include the Muslim side-- are not regimes which really allow, and welcome, and let the truth circulate freely. And until they are, the Hague tribunal will be crying in the wilderness.
是的。巴尔干半岛的悲剧在于，目前真相没有归宿，因为当权的政权，所有这些政权——包括穆斯林一方——都不是真正允许、欢迎并让真相自由传播的政权。在那之前，海牙法庭将在旷野中呼喊。
In his essay, Michael Ignatieff raises this question. To come to terms with the past, do entire nations have to go through the same psychological processes that a person goes through when they face the past? In other words, does there have to be a moment of admitting the truth, of admitting guilt, of feeling shame? We look at a few of those moments, in a very different setting, in a minute, when our program continues.
迈克尔·伊格纳蒂耶夫在文章中提出了这个问题。为了与过去和解，整个国家是否必须经历一个人在面对过去时所经历的同样的心理过程？换句话说，是否必须有一个承认真相、承认罪行、感到羞耻的时刻？一会儿，当我们的节目继续时，我们会在一个非常不同的环境中看看其中的几个时刻。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you radio monologues, miniature documentaries, found tape, anything we can think of on that theme. Today's program, what puts the past to rest?
这里是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你广播独白、迷你纪录片、现成录音，任何我们能想到的关于那个主题的内容。今天的节目，什么能让过去安息？
We are at Act Two, kids. There's a program in Tucson, Arizona that says, basically, the reason teenagers do so badly in the juvenile justice system is that they're tried and convicted not by their peers-- that is, by other teenagers-- but by adults, outsiders. Scott Carrier visited a Tucson courtroom set up with the premise that teenagers would be tried and convicted by other teenagers.
我们进入第二幕，孩子。亚利桑那州图森市有一个项目，基本上说，青少年在少年司法系统中表现如此糟糕的原因是，他们不是由同龄人——也就是其他青少年——审判和定罪的，而是由成年人、局外人审判和定罪的。斯科特·卡里尔参观了一个图森法庭，该法庭的前提是青少年将由其他青少年审判和定罪。
I'm guilty. One minute into the first trial the prosecuting attorney stands up to examine the witness. She's beautiful, a knockout blond in a tight black cashmere sweater. She's maybe 17, but in teen court, everyone has a role to play, and she plays the prosecutor very well.
我有罪。第一场审判进行了一分钟，检察官起身讯问证人。她很漂亮，是一个穿着紧身黑色羊绒衫的迷人金发女郎。她可能17岁，但在青少年法庭，每个人都有角色要扮演，她扮演的检察官非常出色。
Why didn't you go to your room, was the question that your attorney asked you, and you can't answer that? Why didn't you go to your room? You have no idea why you wouldn't go to your room?
你的律师问你为什么没回房间，而你答不上来？你为什么不回房间？你根本不知道你为什么不回房间吗？
No.
不知道。
The boy on the stand is 12, still with baby fat, hair slicked back to look cool. His crime was to file a false report to 911, said his mom was hitting him.
站在证人席上的男孩12岁，还有婴儿肥，头发向后梳显得很酷。他的罪名是向911虚假报警，说他妈妈在打他。
Do you know what 911 is used for?
你知道911是用来干什么的吗？
Umm, sort of.
嗯，大概吧。
What is it used for?
它是用来干什么的？
To help people.
帮助别人。
It's an emergency-only type of phone call, like if there's an intruder in your house, or someone really is abusing you to the point of where you're scared for your life. Do you think this fits into an emergency? I mean, now that you can think about it, do you think that you should have called them?
这是一个仅用于紧急情况的电话，比如如果有闯入者进了你家，或者有人真的虐待你到了让你害怕生命危险的地步。你认为这符合紧急情况吗？我的意思是，现在你能思考了，你认为你应该打给他们吗？
No.
不。
The mother tells me her son is a Tohono O'odham Indian, that she adopted him when he was five, and that he's always been angry-- angry at her, angry at a lot of things. They got into an argument. The boy said, "Why don't you just hit me? Go ahead, hit me." And she did. She slugged him in the arm, and the boy called 911.
母亲告诉我，她的儿子是一个托霍诺·奥哈姆印第安人，她在男孩五岁时领养了他，他一直很生气——生她的气，生很多事情的气。他们吵了一架。男孩说：“你为什么不直接打我？来吧，打我。”于是她打了。她在他手臂上重重打了一下，男孩就打了911。
There are about 250 teen courts in 30 states around the country, and their number is increasing rapidly, because they seem to work. In Tucson, the recidivism rate for kids who go through teen court is only 8%, compared with 37% for kids who go through regular juvenile court for similar minor offenses. The social workers, judges, lawyers, and the policemen who work and volunteer for teen court are convinced that it's a good program. They surround the kids with attention, try to show them that they care, that there's a whole community that cares.
全国30个州有大约250个青少年法庭，而且数量正在迅速增加，因为它们似乎很有效。在图森，青少年法庭的少管所复发率只有8%，而类似轻微犯罪进入正规青少年法庭的青少年复发率则是37%。为青少年法庭工作和自愿服务的社会工作者、法官、律师和警察都确信这是一个好项目。他们用关注包围孩子，试图向他们展示他们关心，整个社区都在关心。
But if you ask them why it works, they usually say it's the jury process of having the kids explain themselves and their actions to a jury of their peers, other teenagers, and then hearing their response, that this has an unusual, even amazing, rehabilitative effect. In this case, however, this part of the process seems to be more about shame.
但如果你问他们为什么有效，他们通常会说这是陪审团程序，让孩子们向同龄人陪审团——其他青少年——解释他们自己和他们的行为，然后听取他们的反应，这具有不同寻常的，甚至是令人惊叹的康复效果。然而，在这个案例中，过程的这一部分似乎更多是关于羞耻。
Are you aware that you provoked your mother to hit you? It sounds to me like you provoked her, didn't you?
你知道是你挑衅你母亲打你的吗？听起来是你挑衅了她，对吗？
Yeah.
是。
Why would you want your mother to hit you?
你为什么要让你母亲打你？
To see what she would do.
看看她会做什么。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know.
不知道。
So it was like an experimentation. You were testing your mother to see if she'd actually hit you?
所以就像实验。你在测试你母亲看她是否真的会打你？
Yeah.
是。
Why would you do that to somebody, especially your mother?
你为什么要对某人这样做，尤其是你的母亲？
In theory, if things were to go as planned, the boy as offender, as breaker of the law, should tell the jury that he recognizes his responsibility for the offense and its consequences, and apologize, and say he'll try not to do it again. But instead, up on the stand, he decides that maybe he wasn't so wrong in calling 911, that this wasn't the first time his mother hit him, and she hits his little brother, too.
理论上，如果事情按计划进行，作为违法者的男孩应该告诉陪审团，他承认自己对犯罪行为及其后果负责，并道歉，说他会尽量不再这样做。但相反，在证人席上，他觉得也许他打911并不那么错，因为这不是他母亲第一次打他，她也打他弟弟。
This is a mistake, and in her closing argument, the prosecutor asks the jury to remember that the boy is not sorry, that he isn't admitting his responsibility.
这是一个错误，在结案陈词中，检察官要求陪审团记住，男孩并不后悔，他并没有承认自己的责任。
Would the bailiff please take the jury to the jury room?
法警请把陪审团带到陪审室好吗？
All rise.
全体起立。
The jury is comprised of eight teenagers. Seven of them have been in teen court before as defendants, and they're serving jury duty as part of their sentences. The eighth juror is a girl who's doing this for credit at her private school. She's eager to be the foreman of the jury. She speaks right up and asks if there are any objections to her being the foreperson, and no one objects, of course, so she gets right down to it.
陪审团由八名青少年组成。其中七人之前曾以被告身份进入青少年法庭，他们正在服陪审团义务，作为惩罚的一部分。第八名陪审员是一个女孩，她正在为私立学校的学分做这件事。她渴望成为陪审团领班。她直接站起来问大家对她成为领班有没有异议，当然没人有异议，所以她直接开始了。
I think he should get the self-esteem workshop, because it really seems like he needs that. He called 911 for really no reason, and because of kids like him, kids who--
我认为他应该参加自尊研讨会，因为他似乎真的很需要那个。他无缘无故地打了911，而且因为像他这样的孩子……
They launch into a discussion where they say all the things that adults usually say about teenagers.
他们展开了一场讨论，说了所有成年人通常会对青少年说的话。
The way he acted in there, it's not acceptable. I think he doesn't have respect for anything, and he doesn't take this seriously.
他在那里的行为是不可接受的。我认为他什么都不尊重，而且他不把这当回事。
I don't think his parents hit him enough, or something. He does what he wants, and he doesn't even listen to his mom or nothing. And he has, like, a real bad attitude. And like, he don't care what anybody thinks, and I think they should hit him, just to show him.
我不认为他父母打他够狠，或者什么的。他想干嘛就干嘛，甚至不听他妈妈的。而且他的态度真的很差。他根本不在乎别人怎么想，我认为他们应该打他，只是为了展示给他看。
I think that he needs to respect his parents more, which he doesn't, so when his mom says to go to his room, he should do it, instead of saying, hit me, mom, hit me.
我认为他需要更多地尊重父母，而他没有，所以当他妈妈叫他回房间时，他应该照做，而不是说，打我，妈，打我。
Everyone's saying he should have respect for his elders, but I mean, we don't know what happened before he started provoking her. Like, I don't know, I mean, like if she started cussing at him or something, I mean, she should have respect for him, too. It's both ways.
每个人都说他应该尊重长辈，但我的意思是，我们不知道他在挑衅她之前发生了什么。比如，我不知道，我的意思是，如果她开始对他骂脏话什么的，我的意思是，她也应该尊重他。这是双向的。
This girl is 13 years old, and really petite. She's been in teen court twice already, once for possession of marijuana, and again for hitting her mother-- domestic violence.
这个女孩13岁，非常娇小。她已经两次进入青少年法庭，一次是因为持有大麻，另一次是因为殴打母亲——家庭暴力。
We don't really know what really goes on in that house. We can't say that that was the first time he was hit. Maybe he got hit a lot of times before.
我们真的不知道家里到底发生了什么。我们不能说那是他第一次被打。也许他以前被打过很多次。
She's the only jurist to try to see things from the boy's point of view, most likely because she's been there. She really is his peer. She gets into a lot of trouble, and fights with her mother. She argues for the defendant, but the others will have none of it. He's guilty and he's not sorry. He needs to be taught a lesson.
她是唯一试图从男孩的角度看待问题的陪审员，很有可能是因为她也经历过同样的事情。她真的是他的同龄人。她惹了很多麻烦，也和母亲打架。她为被告辩护，但其他人不买账。他有罪，而且他不后悔。他需要被教训一下。
Surprisingly, it turns out that the petite girl, even though she seems to understand the boy, she's willing to punish him just as much as any of the others. I ask her how she would help the boy, and she says she'd put him in juvenile jail.
令人惊讶的是，结果娇小的女孩尽管似乎理解男孩，但她愿意像其他人一样惩罚他。我问她她会怎么帮助那个男孩，她说她会把他送进少年感化院。
Probably send him to juvie for maybe a couple days.
可能会把他送进感化院几天。
Have you been to juvie?
你去过感化院吗？
Yeah, for just a couple hours, though.
去过，不过就几个小时。
Why is that a good thing? Why would it be a good thing for him?
为什么那是件好事？为什么这对他来说是件好事？
I don't know, just keep him away from his parents for a little bit. And that way he could see that if it happens again, he'll know where he'll be.
不知道，只是让他远离父母一会儿。这样他就能看到，如果再发生这种情况，他就会知道他会在哪里。
I've been told that teenage juries are notoriously more harsh in their sentencing than regular juvenile court judges, that perhaps this is because teenagers are being asked to act as adults, and they know from experience how adults act in these situations. Adults punish. Or perhaps, the kids, from experience, know what really works is to make it hurt.
我听说青少年陪审团在量刑时比正规青少年法官严厉得多，也许这是因为青少年被要求像成年人一样行事，他们从经验中知道成年人在这些情况下是如何行事的。成年人惩罚。或者也许，孩子们从经验中知道真正有效的方法是让它感到疼痛。
The organizers and administrators of teen court try to discourage the idea of punishment. They try, instead, to encourage corrective sentencing that will help the kids, teach them, not hurt them. There's the minimum sentence, consisting of jury duty, letters of apology, and a basic course in responsible decision-making.
青少年法庭的组织者和行政人员试图劝阻惩罚的想法。相反，他们试图鼓励纠正性量刑，这将帮助孩子，教导他们，而不是伤害他们。有最低刑期，包括陪审团义务、道歉信和基础负责任决策课程。
But the jury can, if it decides the defendant needs additional corrections, require that he perform manual labor, such as painting over graffiti, or making him attend and successfully complete a self-esteem workshop, five one-and-a-half-hour sessions in which they learn skills for non-violent problem solving, and increasing belief in internal versus external control-over-life events. Topics include identification and expression of emotions, anger, safety planning, and personal power.
但如果陪审团认为被告需要额外的纠正，可以要求他从事体力劳动，例如清理涂鸦，或者让他参加并圆满完成自尊研讨会，五个每次一个半小时的课程，学习非暴力解决问题的技巧，增强对内在而非外在生活控制的信念。主题包括识别和表达情绪、愤怒、安全计划和个人力量。
In this case, the case of the false report, since they cannot send the boy to prison, they send him to self-esteem workshops, two for good measure, and give him a day's labor in the community garden.
在这个案例中，即虚假报警案，因为他们不能把男孩送进监狱，所以他们送他去参加自尊研讨会，为了保险起见送两个，并让他去社区花园劳动一天。
The next trial concerns a 13-year-old who was caught with a smoking bowl, a marijuana pipe out behind the school. He's been suspended for five weeks, and his dad tells me this is excessive punishment, not constructive at all, because his son is just missing out on his classes, just sits at home all day. He says he thinks the teen court system is a good thing, better than the juvenile court, but basically, he just doesn't like seeing his son put through the wringer by anyone other than himself.
下一场审判涉及一个13岁的孩子，他在学校后面被发现拿着一个还在冒烟的大麻烟斗。他被停学五周，他爸爸告诉我这是过度的惩罚，根本没有建设性，因为他儿子只是错过了课程，整天坐在家里。他说他认为青少年法庭体系是件好事，比青少年法庭好，但基本上，他只是不喜欢看到儿子被除他自己以外的任何人折磨。
On the stand, his son says he's sorry, that he knows he did something wrong. He gets emotional, nearly starts crying, and I look over at his dad, and he's just hating it. His son is 13 years old and big for his age. His son is 13 years old and starting to be a man, and his son has just been shamed in public.
在证人席上，他儿子说他很抱歉，他知道自己做错了什么。他情绪激动，几乎开始哭泣，我看向他爸爸，他真的很讨厌这样。他儿子13岁，个头比同龄人高。他儿子13岁，开始成为一个男人，而他儿子刚刚在公共场合蒙羞。
This time, in the jury room, nearly everyone is in favor of letting the defendant off easy. The private school girl wants to send him to self-esteem classes, but no one else seems to agree.
这次在陪审室里，几乎每个人都赞成从轻发落。私立学校的女孩想送他去自尊课，但其他人似乎不同意。
That doesn't have nothing to do with this. I mean, he doesn't have low self-esteem. Obviously, he doesn't.
那跟这个没关系。我的意思是，他没有低自尊。很显然，他没有。
But she said the self-esteem workshop is not just self-esteem.
但她说自尊研讨会不仅仅是自尊。
Oh, I know, but all that's going to be, it's five classes, all that's going to be is something where he sits there and watches the clock the whole time.
哦，我知道，但那能有什么用，就五节课，那只会是他在那里整节课盯着时钟看。
They make everybody participate.
他们让每个人都参与。
Like, if I saw him on the street, just the way he looks, it doesn't look to me like he has low esteem. But she knows that he gets high, so now he has low esteem.
比如，如果我在街上看到他，就他那个样子，对我来说看起来他不像是低自尊。但他知道他嗑药，所以现在他有低自尊了。
I'm pretty sure that all of us, except for probably one person, have used marijuana, so we all know how it feels, and do all of us have low self esteem? No? OK, then.
我很确定我们所有人，除了一个人外，都用过大麻，所以我们都知道是什么感觉，难道我们所有人都有低自尊吗？不？好的，就这样。
There's a jury monitor in the room, a professional social worker who's overseeing the deliberation, and it seems like things are not going in the direction she'd hoped for. She tries to move the kids to a decision by taking a vote. She counts four in favor of self-esteem and four against. But I count four against, one in favor, and three who will not say one way or the other.
房间里有一名陪审团监督员，一名负责监督审议的专业社会工作者，事情似乎并没有朝着她希望的方向发展。她试图通过投票促使孩子们做出决定。她数了四票支持自尊，四票反对。但我数了四票反对，一票支持，还有三票不说支持也不说反对。
It turns into a discussion about who needs self-esteem, how to measure it, and that maybe they don't even know what self-esteem means. Then the little girl comes up with an idea. She asks if the defendant has ever tried to commit suicide.
讨论演变成了关于谁需要自尊、如何衡量自尊，以及也许他们甚至不知道自尊是什么意思。然后小女孩想到了一个主意。她问被告是否曾经尝试自杀。
I'm wondering if he's ever tried to commit suicide. I mean, people that try that probably have a low self-esteem.
我想知道他是否曾经尝试自杀。我的意思是，尝试过的人可能自尊心很低。
So you want me to go ask him?
所以你想让我去问他？
Yeah, because that's what you call low self-esteem.
对，因为那就是你所谓的低自尊。
OK, I'll be right back.
好的，我马上回来。
While the social worker's out of the room, I ask the kids what they really think about marijuana.
当社会工作者离开房间时，我问孩子们他们对大麻的真正想法。
You know, if you had a party or something, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] drinking, I think drinking messes you up more. You have more chances of dying than getting high.
你知道，如果你有一个派对什么的，[听不清]喝酒，我认为喝酒对你的损害更大。你死亡的几率比嗑药高多了。
What do the rest of you think? You've been busted for marijuana.
你们其他人怎么想？你们因为大麻被抓过。
She sells it, man.
她卖那玩意儿，伙计。
I don't anymore. I mean, you can't really think bad about the people, because there's lots of different people that use it, and different reasons, and just different stuff.
我不再卖了。我的意思是，你不能真正地去评价那些人，因为有许多不同的人使用它，为了不同的原因，只是不同的事情。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] even the president got high.
[听不清]甚至总统也嗑药。
He did.
他嗑过。
He says he never inhaled.
他说他从没吸进去。
Well, he can say it all he wants, you know he did.
嗯，他想怎么说就怎么说，你知道他嗑了。
He says that if he had a chance, he would again.
他说如果他有机会，他还会嗑。
Yeah, he probably would.
是的，他可能会。
Yeah, and that's the president.
是的，而且那是总统。
I'd smoke a joint with him.
我会和他一起抽一支烟。
So is this a bad person? Is this guy a bad person for smoking?
所以这是一个坏人吗？这家伙因为抽这个就是一个坏人吗？
No.
不。
I'm not judging him because he gets high, that's nothing. I don't even care.
我没有因为他嗑药而评判他，那算什么。我甚至不在乎。
It's his own problem, it's not ours.
这是他自己的问题，不是我们的。
But it's not just his problem, it's society's problem. We are part of society, and we're brought in here so he doesn't grow up doing it and become a bigger problem for society.
但这不仅仅是他自己的问题，这是社会的问题。我们是社会的一部分，我们被带到这里是为了让他长大后不去这样做，成为社会更大的问题。
The one girl who's an outsider here, the one who goes to a private school, she doesn't let up, and it becomes clear that everyone else is turning against her.
这里唯一的那个外来者，那个去私立学校的女孩，她不肯罢休，很明显其他所有人都站在了她的对立面。
I'm the only kid in my neighborhood who doesn't do it. I go to a private school, I go to a Catholic parochial school--
我是我附近唯一一个不碰那玩意的孩子。我去的是私立学校，我去的是天主教教区学校——
Exactly, I don't go to a private school, I go to--
没错，我不去私立学校，我去——
And I'm the only kid in the eighth grade who doesn't do it, because I have better stuff to do. I want to go to college. I don't want my brain to turn into mush.
而且我是八年级唯一一个不碰那玩意的孩子，因为我有更有意义的事情做。我想上大学。我不想让我的大脑变成浆糊。
You know what, but if you get high one time--
你知道吗，但如果你嗑一次——
That's a stereotype.
那是刻板印象。
It ain't going to hurt you.
它不会伤害你。
I don't care, I've done it, you know. And I do it, but I still, I'm going to graduate this year, and it's there. I'm mean, it's stupid maybe that I do it, but that's your opinion, whatever [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我不在乎，我做过，你知道。而且我做这件事，但我还是，我今年要毕业了，它就在那里。我的意思是，也许我这样做很蠢，但那是你的观点，随你便[听不清]。
Same here, man. I mean, I've smoked it through high school, and I'm still graduating this year.
我也一样，伙计。我的意思是，我在高中时就抽过，而且我今年还是会毕业。
Just because he smokes weed doesn't mean he's going to have a bad life like she said.
仅仅因为他抽大麻并不意味着他会像她说的那样有一个糟糕的人生。
But do we want to take that chance?
但我们想冒那个险吗？
Chance of what?
冒什么险？
Of him growing up smoking weed a lot. Weed is the gateway drug.
他长大后大量抽大麻的风险。大麻是入门毒品。
The social worker comes back in the room and tells them that the defendant has never tried to kill himself, and because his self-esteem seems intact, because his crime is one most of the jurors have committed themselves, because they are united against the private school girl, they give him the minimum sentence.
社会工作者回到房间，告诉他们被告从未尝试自杀，并且因为他的自尊心似乎很完整，因为他的罪行大多数陪审员自己都犯过，因为他们团结一致反对私立学校的女孩，他们给了他最低刑期。
In the third trial, a 14-year-old girl is on the stand for physically assaulting a former friend. The former friend had been spreading a rumor that she, the friend, had slept with the 14-year-old girl's boyfriend. She said the boyfriend got her pregnant.
在第三场审判中，一名14岁的女孩站在证人席上，因为身体攻击了一名前朋友。那个前朋友一直在散布谣言，说她，那个朋友，和14岁女孩的男朋友睡过了。她说男朋友让她怀孕了。
The 14-year-old told her to stop, but she did it again to another boy, and another girlfriend. So the 14-year-old girl went over to her house, pulled her by her hair off the front steps and into the yard, and punched her in the face. Her defense attorney tries to get her to say she's sorry, that she won't do it again.
14岁的女孩让她停止，但她又对另一个男孩和另一个女朋友这样做。于是14岁的女孩跑到她家，把她从台阶上拖下来，拖进院子里，打了她的脸。她的辩护律师试图让她道歉，说她不会再做了。
Why did you do what you did?
你为什么要那样做？
Bad temper.
脾气坏。
What are your feelings now about what you did?
你现在对你所做的事情有什么感受？
It really doesn't bother me, because I did it, and can't take it back, so.
这对我真的没什么影响，因为我已经做了，而且无法收回，所以。
Thank you, no further questions, Your Honor.
谢谢，没有更多问题了，法官大人。
Cross-examination.
交叉询问。
Thank you, Your Honor. You lost your temper and got into a fight, right? Because she provoked you? Now, if I walked up here like this, and I started talking massive crap to your face, would you hit me because I provoked you?
谢谢，法官大人。你发脾气打了一架，对吗？因为她挑衅你？现在，如果我像这样走过去，我开始对着你的脸说极其难听的话，你会因为我挑衅你而打我吗？
Maybe.
可能会。
Maybe. It doesn't bother you now that you got in a fight?
可能会。你现在因为打了一架而感到难过吗？
No.
不。
No. Why?
不。为什么？
Fighting's an everyday thing. It doesn't really make a big difference. It happens, then it's over.
打架是家常便饭。它真的没有多大区别。发生了，然后就结束了。
It happens then it's over? Everyday thing?
发生了，然后就结束了？家常便饭？
Yeah, it's not nothing. It's not like getting shot, or stabbed, or dying. You just get a few marks, maybe.
是的，这没什么。这不像被枪击、被捅或者死。你只是得到几个印记，也许。
It's against the law. Whether there's a gun, a knife, or dying involved, fighting is against the law, just like smoking, just like everything else, just like killing. It's against the law. It shouldn't be done. That's why you're here today. Can you tell this jury that you're not going to fight again?
这是违法的。无论是否涉及枪支、刀具或死亡，打架都是违法的，就像抽烟一样，就像其他一切一样，就像杀人一样。这是违法的。不应该这样做。这就是你今天在这里的原因。你能告诉陪审团你不会再打架了吗？
No.
不。
No further questions.
没有更多问题了。
This trial has a different jury. When they debate, no one mentions the statement by the defendant, that in her neighborhood, fighting is an everyday thing, no big deal, really. It either just flew over their heads, or it doesn't make any difference to them.
这场审判有不同的陪审团。当他们辩论时，没有人提到被告的陈述，即在她的邻里，打架是家常便饭，没什么大不了的，真的。要么它根本没入他们的耳朵，要么它对他们没有任何区别。
The most important thing to them is that the defendant feels no remorse, has suffered no shame. And like the first jury, somehow they're certain that shame is the essential ingredient, the first step in changing the criminal into a good citizen.
对他们来说最重要的是，被告没有任何悔意，没有遭受任何羞耻。而且像第一个陪审团一样，他们以某种方式确信羞耻是必要的成分，是把罪犯变成好公民的第一步。
She doesn't feel bad about it at all, you guys, so.
她根本不为此感到难过，各位，所以。
Give her mandatory--
给她强制——
Yeah, mandatory self-esteem, the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
是的，强制自尊，[听不清]。
How many jury duties, one?
多少次陪审团义务，一次？
I think she should have more, like three.
我认为她应该有更多次，比如三次。
Three, yeah, three.
三次，是的，三次。
She's got to learn from other people.
她必须向别人学习。
She doesn't even care, like, she just sits there like-- I think she should go to the self-esteem workshop a couple times.
她根本不在乎，比如，她只是坐在那里像——我认为她应该多去几次自尊研讨会。
You know, you can give her two self-esteem workshops.
你知道，你可以给她两次自尊研讨会。
Can you really?
真的可以吗？
Yeah, two workshops, maximum.
是的，两次研讨会，最多。
I think we should.
我认为我们应该。
Oh, do that, do that.
哦，做吧，做吧。
Yeah, give her two.
是的，给她两次。
Most members of the jury have already been through the workshops. They know what the right answer is. They get excited as they write the comments to the defendants.
大多数陪审团成员已经参加过研讨会。他们知道正确答案是什么。他们在写给被告的评论时感到很兴奋。
Yeah, she needs to hear it. She needs to feel somewhat bad about it.
是的，她需要听到这个。她需要对此感到有点糟糕。
OK, we feel that there will be people that lie and cheat your whole life, to you--
好的，我们觉得会有人撒谎和欺骗你一辈子，对你——
But you can't beat them all up.
但你不能把他们都打一顿。
You have to grow up.
你必须长大。
Use your mind, not your muscles.
动动脑子，别动你的肌肉。
All that's good.
那些都很好。
After they deliver the sentence, the defendant comes down off the stand, and I ask if she wants to talk to me for a little bit, but she looks at me as if she'd like to rip my throat out, like, where's my knife when I need it. She's not been shamed. In her neighborhood, fighting is an everyday thing, a way of life, a way of staying alive. Nobody understood what she was saying.
当他们宣判后，被告走下证人席，我问她是否想和我聊一会儿，但她看着我，好像想把我的喉咙撕开，比如，我需要刀子的时候它在哪儿。她没有蒙羞。在她的邻里，打架是家常便饭，是一种生活方式，一种生存方式。没人听懂她在说什么。
I follow her out of the courtroom and down the hallway, to the room where she'll have her exit interview. I watch her sit down at a long wooden table, surrounded by social workers and police officers, and her body is there, but she is gone, checked out, no longer present for the proceedings. She just isn't going to listen anymore. I can go in and sit down and watch as the administrators try to see whether she understands her sentence, as they try to get through to her, but I don't.
我跟着她走出法庭，沿着走廊来到她进行离职面试的房间。我看着她坐在长木桌旁，被社会工作者和警察包围，她的身体在那里，但她人已经走了，心不在焉，不再出席会议。她只是不再听了。我可以进去坐下来看工作人员是否试图看她是否理解她的判决，当他们试图让她听进去时，但我没有。
Act Three, Everyday Justice. Well, the impulse to confess, to admit the truth, to state your shame, is so important and so basic that, of course, people do not need a trial to make them do it. In 1980, a New Yorker named Allan Bridge set up a telephone line he called the Apology Line. People could call and confess to anything. They were recorded. And you could call and you could listen to other people's confessions recorded on the line.
第三幕，日常正义。好吧，承认的冲动，承认真相，陈述你的羞耻，是如此重要和基础，以至于人们当然不需要通过审判来让他们这样做。1980年，一位名叫艾伦·布里奇的纽约人设立了一条他称之为“道歉热线”的电话线。人们可以打电话来承认任何事情。他们被录音了。而且你可以打电话听听其他人录在电话线上的忏悔。
Over time, the whole thing turned into a little community of confession. People recorded messages responding to each other's apologies. Mr. Apology, Allan Bridge, would leave messages responding. And sometimes he would actually contact callers off the line. Here's some recordings from the line.
随着时间的推移，整个事情变成了一个小的忏悔社区。人们录制信息回应彼此的道歉。道歉先生，艾伦·布里奇，会留下回复信息。有时他真的会在电话线外联系打来电话的人。这是来自电话线的一些录音。
Yes, I'd like to apologize because I broke the town hall windows. I flooded the basement. I broke windows on the back of a store uptown. I feel pretty bad about it because I did so much vandalism. I'm only 16 years old. I did so much vandalism, if I was caught, I'd be in juvie hall for a pretty long time, I'd say.
是的，我想道歉，因为我打破了市政厅的窗户。我淹了地下室。我打破了城里一家商店后面的窗户。我感觉很糟糕，因为我做了那么多破坏行为。我才16岁。我做了那么多破坏行为，如果我被抓，我会在感化院待很长时间，我想。
I'm sorry for harassing the Republican officials, making the bomb threats and the death notices. I'm sorry for the terrorism, the firebombing that the guy paid me to do to some guy's house. I'm sorry for-- ah, what else?-- the burnings in the streets of Smithtown, Long Island.
我很抱歉骚扰了共和党官员，制造了炸弹威胁和死亡通知。我很抱歉恐怖主义，那个家伙付钱让我去炸某人的房子的纵火行为。我很抱歉——啊，还有什么？——长岛史密斯镇街头的纵火。
I'm sorry for the way I'm calling right now. I'm calling by way of a phony credit card. I'm sorry for harassing the teacher in school. I feel bad about it. I'd like to have a new lease on life. What else? I'm sorry for harassing a lot of people, for causing pain to my family. I felt so sad I was sick, I was sick by it. That's all I have to say. Yeah. So long.
我很抱歉我现在的拨号方式。我是通过假信用卡拨打的。我很抱歉骚扰学校里的老师。我对此感到很难过。我希望能有新的人生。还有什么？我很抱歉骚扰了很多人，给我的家人造成了痛苦。我感到如此悲伤，我病了，我为此病了。这就是我要说的全部。是的。再见。
Hello, I'm Israeli. I want to apologize. I don't know if even what I did was wrong or right, but when I was in Israel six months before, I killed six Arabs at night with a gang of other Jewish settlers. And at the time, we thought we were-- I believe still, we're fighting for our homeland, to keep it from the Arabs, but perhaps now that I am here in America, I realized that maybe killing is not the right way, and I want to apologize. Thank you.
你好，我是以色列人。我想道歉。我甚至不知道我所做的是对还是错，但当我六个月前在以色列时，我晚上和一群其他犹太定居者一起杀死了六个阿拉伯人。当时我们以为我们是——我相信现在仍然是，我们是在为我们的家园而战，把它从阿拉伯人手中保住，但也许现在我来到了美国，我意识到杀戮可能不是正确的方式，我想道歉。谢谢。
Yeah, I want to apologize for something. And maybe, my guess is it's too late to apologize for it, but I want to apologize for it now. My mother was bedridden for a while, and she used to get social security and welfare, and I had no job, and I had no way of making money. And when she was hungry or thirsty, I used to make her give me money to give her a drink. Like, she'd have to give me $5 for a glass of water, $10 for a sandwich.
是的，我想为某件事道歉。也许，我的猜测是现在道歉已经太晚了，但我想现在为它道歉。我母亲病卧在床一段时间，她过去经常领社会保障金和福利，我没有工作，我没有赚钱的途径。当她饿了或渴了，我过去常让她给我钱才给她喝的东西。比如，她得给我5美元买一杯水，10美元买一个三明治。
And now she's passed away, and I can't say I'm sorry to her, because I know what I did was probably the most horrible thing in the world. And I'll never be able to say I'm sorry to her. And I hope I go to hell and burn there for this, because it wasn't right. And if there's somewhere that she can hear me, I just want to tell her I'm sorry. Thank you.
现在她去世了，我不能对她说对不起，因为我知道我所做的是世界上最可怕的事情。我永远无法对她说对不起。我希望我下地狱并在那里燃烧，因为这不对。如果有什么地方她能听到我说话，我只想告诉她对不起。谢谢。
I've never told anyone this, except my shrink. I accidentally killed my younger sister when I was a very small child. And it's haunted me all my life, because I didn't really mean it. It was just a game to me. I was really too young to realize what I was doing. And I was putting her head inside a plastic garbage bag and putting a rubber band around her neck, just to see her face turn blue. And I guess it was a lot of fun.
除了我的精神科医生，我从来没告诉过任何人。我还是个很小的孩子时意外杀死了我的妹妹。它困扰了我一辈子，因为我并不是真的想那样做。对我来说那只是个游戏。我当时真的太小了，没有意识到我在做什么。我把她的头塞进一个塑料垃圾袋里，在她的脖子上套了一根橡皮筋，只是想看她的脸变蓝。我想这很有趣。
And I didn't mean anything bad to happen, but I guess I didn't realize what would happen if I did this too long. And she suffocated. And I hid the plastic bag, and I went out of the house. My parents weren't home. And they never found out. They thought it was crib death, they never found out I did it.
我并不是想让任何坏事发生，但我猜我没有意识到如果我这样做太久会发生什么。然后她窒息了。我藏起了塑料袋，我走出了房子。我父母不在家。他们从来没发现。他们以为是婴儿猝死症，他们永远没发现是我做的。
And you know, I've never been able to tell them. I think it would hurt them worse than losing her, to find out that I did it. I kind of wish my parents could hear this tape, but I guess they never will.
你知道，我从来没能告诉他们。我想如果发现是我做的，那对他们来说比失去她更痛苦。我有点希望我父母能听到这段录音，但我猜他们永远不会。
Hi. I'm a runaway, and all I want to say is that I'm kind of sorry that I left. See, I'm 15, and I saw your number in the newspaper. And when I saw it, I had to call, because it's like, I mean, you walk around on the streets all day long, just looking for someone who just might say, hey, want a place to go? Come with me. There could be food and everything. And they won't ask for anything back. That's all I want. I guess I take up too much time on the tape, but I've just got to talk.
嗨。我是个离家出走的孩子，我只想说我有点后悔我离开了。你看，我15岁，我在报纸上看到了你的号码。当我看到它时，我不得不打，因为这就像，我的意思是，你整天在街上走来走去，只是在寻找某个人，也许会说，嘿，想有个地方去吗？跟我来。那里可能有食物和一切。他们不会要求任何回报。这就是我想要的一切。我想我在录音带上花太多时间了，但我必须得说。
The Apology Line doesn't exist anymore. Mr. Apology, Allan Bridge, died in August of 1995. When he did, the line was deluged with hundreds of messages from its regular callers, grieving. His wife Marissa says it was never clear what the Apology Line had meant to people. For years, people had used it to talk about all sorts of experiences.
道歉热线已经不存在了。道歉先生，艾伦·布里奇，死于1995年8月。当他去世时，电话线被数百条来自其常客的哀悼信息淹没了。他的妻子玛丽莎说，道歉热线对人们意味着什么从来都不清楚。多年来，人们一直用它来谈论各种各样的经历。
I think that maybe the word apology means something bigger than just saying you're sorry. Or at least, maybe not the word, but the line came to mean to people a place where one could go and bring their feelings, to confess, not necessarily about doing something wrong, but to confess about having a feeling.
我认为道歉这个词可能意味着比说对不起更大的东西。或者至少，也许不是这个词，但这条线对人们来说意味着一个可以去并带上他们的感受，忏悔的地方，不一定是因为做了什么错事，而是忏悔有一种感受。
When he was alive, would you ever call the line, or be tempted to call the line?
当他活着的时候，你会打电话或者想打那个电话吗？
I called the line in the beginning. When I first knew him, before I moved in with him, I called the line from time to time.
我在一开始打过电话。当我刚认识他时，在我搬去和他住之前，我不时地打过。
And you'd apologize for stuff?
你会为事情道歉吗？
Well, yeah, sometimes, but more to get his attention than anything else. So he wouldn't forget about me up in Washington Heights, where I was living.
嗯，是的，有时，但更多的是为了引起他的注意，而不是其他。这样他就不会忘记我在华盛顿高地，我住的地方。
What would you apologize for back then? Do you remember what you would say?
你那时会为什么道歉？你还记得你会说什么吗？
They were all like, you know, just to get his attention. Things like, I'm really sorry I was flirting with another guy, or something like that, all very much part of the mating game.
它们都像，你知道，只是为了引起他的注意。比如，我很抱歉我和另一个家伙调情了，或者类似的事情，都非常属于求偶游戏的一部分。
And once you actually had a real relationship with him, you wouldn't call the line, and you didn't feel the need to ever?
而一旦你真正和他建立了关系，你就不会打那个电话了，你也不觉得有任何需要？
No, but one thing that really struck me was after he died, I really turned into an Apology Line caller, someone I would define as Apology Line caller. And the line was over, so when I really needed the line, it wasn't there.
不，但有一件事真正震撼我的是在他去世后，我真的变成了一个道歉热线的打号人，我会定义为道歉热线打号人的人。电话线已经结束了，所以当我真正需要它时，它不在那里。
I was just completely lost, and I would have loved to have been able to call the Apology Line and have someone like Allan on the other side, very sympathetic and understanding, to help me get through it. But unfortunately, that didn't happen. So I'm a much darker person than I was before he died, and I think that I understand the callers and the line much better than I even did before.
我完全迷失了，我本来会很喜欢能够拨打道歉热线，让像艾伦这样的人在另一端，非常同情和理解，来帮助我度过难关。但不幸的是，这没有发生。所以我是一个比他去世前阴暗得多的人，而且我想我比以前更能理解那些打号人和这条线了。
He died in this scuba accident where he was hit by a jet skier, who then fled the scene and wasn't caught. Have you thought about the kinds of people who would call the line, who used to call the line all the time, who had done bad things to other people, and hurt other people, and you know, then would flee the scene and nobody would ever know? Have you thought about those jet skiers in terms of that, in terms of the people who used to call the line?
他死于这次潜水事故，他被一个摩托艇手撞了，然后那人逃离了现场，没有被抓到。你想过那些会打电话、一直打电话、对别人做了坏事、伤害别人、你知道，然后逃离现场而没人会发现的人吗？你想过那些摩托艇手，就那些事，就那些以前打电话的人吗？
Yes. In fact, the person that hit him would also be a prime candidate for the Apology Line, because we think that he knew that he did something, because there were witnesses that saw the accident, and they saw someone on a jet ski hit him, they circled around once and then took off, so yeah.
是的。事实上，撞他的人也会是道歉热线的主要候选人，因为我们认为他知道他做了什么，因为有目击者看到了事故，他们看到有人骑摩托艇撞了他，他们绕了一圈然后逃走了，所以是的。
But you can imagine those people actually calling the line. If they would've called the line, if the line had existed for them, what would've happened? What would Mr. Apology have said if he were around to say it?
但你能想象那些人真的打电话吗？如果他们真的打电话了，如果这条线为他们存在，会发生什么？如果道歉先生还在，他会说什么？
I think he would be pretty pissed off, but he would forgive them. I think that's how he would have gone for it. I think he would have been angry that he was hit. That was a total accident, but I think that if they would have apologized for hitting him, he would have forgiven them, because I think that forgiveness was a big part of his personality. I think he really believed in the power of forgiveness, and everyone can be forgiven if they're sorry. I think that's something that he really believed in.
我想他会很生气，但他会原谅他们。我认为这就是他会对待它的方式。我想他会因为被撞而生气。那是一次完全的意外，但我想如果他们为撞他而道歉，他会原谅他们的，因为我认为宽恕是他个性中很大的一部分。我认为他真的相信宽恕的力量，如果他们感到抱歉，每个人都可以被宽恕。我认为那是他真正相信的东西。
Marissa Bridge, Mrs. Apology.
玛丽莎·布里奇，道歉夫人。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel, Paul Tough, and myself, with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Jack Hitt and Margy Rochlin.
嗯，我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、保罗·塔夫和我自己制作，还有彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克。特约编辑杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
For information about the Apology Line, you can call this number, 212-255-2748. If you'd like a copy of any of our programs, call us at WBEZ in Chicago. They only cost $10. The phone number, 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
有关道歉热线的信息，你可以拨打这个号码，212-255-2748。如果你想要我们节目的拷贝，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ。它们只要10美元。电话号码，312-832-3380，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds you that--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他提醒你——
Weed is the gateway drug.
大麻是入门毒品。
Sure is. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
确实是。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
Now if I start talking massive crap to your face, would you hit me because I provoked you?
现在如果我开始对着你的脸说极其难听的话，你会因为我挑衅你而打我吗？
Maybe.
可能会。